our chief white house correspondent john
roberts live for us on the north lawn
and john
what are we expecting from the
candidates today well you could probably
expect to hear more about coronavirus
and vaccines and mass squaring and
everything
the president headed to moscone
wisconsin the real clear politics
average still shows biden with a
substantial lead there about six points
but the president does believe that
he can bring that within striking
distance for election day and then
joe biden will be in his birthplace of
scranton pennsylvania which the
president likes to remind
is no longer his home for a cnn town
hall the president was there for an abc
town hall
on tuesday the president white house
aides meantime pushing back hard against
what the cdc director dr robert redfield
said yesterday about
vaccines potentially not being available
to the general public
until next summer at a briefing
yesterday i asked the president what he
thought about that timeline
they said that the vaccine for the
general public
likely would not be available until
probably next summer maybe even early
fall
are you comfortable with that time no i
think he made a mistake when he said
that it's just
incorrect information and i called him
and he didn't tell me that and i think
he got the message maybe confused maybe
it was stated incorrectly no we're ready
to go immediately
as the vaccine is announced and it could
be announced in october
could be announced a little bit after
october
the president told me that after
redfield said that to congress
he called the cdc director to ask him
why he said it
the white house insists that while high
risk individuals and frontline workers
will get the first crack at the vaccine
there will be 700 million doses
available by the end of the first
quarter
that would be the end of march 2021
number of months before redfield said it
would be available
the president also criticizing joe biden
for engaging in what he called anti-vaxx
rhetoric biden yesterday
casting doubt on anything that comes out
of the white house before the election
listen here
so let me be clear i trust vaccines
i trust scientists but i don't
trust donald trump the white house also
pushing back against what dr redfield
said about mask wearing redfield
testifying yesterday that masks may be
more effective
at controlling the spread of coronavirus
than a vaccine
here's the white house chief of staff
mark meadows this morning
when you look at if if mass is the
panacea for everything then we can have
everybody going back to work if they'll
just wear a mask and i don't know that
that dr redfield would say that
i can tell you other doctors don't say
that but if that's the way that we open
back our economy and get everybody back
to work i will gladly wear my mask each
and every day
if that's what what makes the difference
and it doesn't
redfield clarifying his testimony in a
pair of tweets yesterday writing quote i
100
believe in the importance of vaccines
and the importance in particular of a
covid19 vaccine a covid19 vaccine
is the thing that will get americans
back to normal everyday life he went on
to say the best defense
we currently have against this virus so
the important mitigation efforts of
wearing a mask
washing your hands social distancing and
being careful about crowds
it is true that hhs and the fda will
take the lead in the development
the approval and distribution of a
vaccine
but for there to be such a split between
the white house and the cdc director is
indeed unusual joe biden meantime saying
he believes that as president he would
have the authority trace
to issue a national mask wearing mandate
if states don't comply with it i think
you might get a legal challenge on that
front
trace one or two john roberts live for
us at the white house